because
[Music]
thank you
anything
important
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everybody
Mr President Mr Provost Madam Secretary
Dean's College heads College Deans
colleagues friends families and most of
all members of the class of 2023.
welcome to this day and congratulations
[Applause]
I call on the University chaplain
with deep gratitude to the Quinnipiac
people for the land on which we stand my
beloved Yale family
I invite you to join me in the spirit of
Prayer
almighty God
you are the one who gives us this day in
all our days
in the Majesty of this life moment we
your beloved children of different
colors Creeds Generations stories and
tongues are gathered in this place
as one human family
United and jubilant celebration
we are filled with gratitude for our
families friends teachers and guides
their arms have sheltered us
their shoulders have boosted us
and today their hearts soar for us
Eternal God it is you who calls us to
our full Humanity
as we celebrate our accomplishments we
are humbled and overwhelmed by what lies
ahead
we live in a world fraught with
heartache and our time at Yale has been
a blend of loss
uncertainty Discovery and reconnection
steady us so that we may find ways to
caress the beauty of your creation
and let our souls know true Delight as
we awaken to the Wonder and mystery of
our own unfolding lives
through the unity of Mind and Spirit
hold us ever close as we seek to leaven
your world wisely
instead fast Pursuit
of your light and your truth
for this we say
amen
oh
oh that which pervades Earth sky and
Heaven
which is worthy of worship
that has no beginning
that which is the light of wisdom and
Truth
let us meditate on the radiance of that
divinity
May that Brilliance help Inspire and
illuminate our minds
that one which represents water
light and is the quintessence of all
things
May that Almighty Spirit pervading the
Earth
atmosphere and Heaven bless us with
enlightenment
send forth your light and your truth
they will lead me
they will bring me to your Holy Mountain
to your Dwelling Place
that I may come
to the altar of God
my delight
my joy
that I may praise you
with the harp
oh God
my God
you are the light of the world
a City built on a hill cannot be hid
no one after lighting a lamp puts it
under the Bissell basket but on the lamp
stand and it gives light to all in the
house
in the same way let your light shine
before others so that they may see your
good works and give glory to your God in
heaven
God is the light of the heavens and
earth the likeness of his light is that
of a niche in which there is a lamp the
lamp is in a glass
the glass is as it were a brilliant star
lit from a blessed tree an olive tree
neither of the East nor of the West
whose oil seems to Glow even though no
fire has touched it
light upon light
God guides whom he Wills to his light
God makes Parables for Humanity and God
has knowledge of everything
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Joyful Joyful rehears
like us before we fall into the sun
above
away
[Music]
fill us with the light of day
all thy works with choice
[Music]
to rejoice
foreign
[Music]
graduates
parents friends president saliva
chaplain coogler
and colleagues on the faculty and staff
I'd like to start by thanking our
students who did those beautiful
readings thank you
on this this occasion it's uh which is
Baccalaureate it is customary for the
president to deliver an address and for
the dean of Yale College to offer a
reading
this is only my first year as Dean but
I've been teaching at Yale for a quarter
of a century so I've had the opportunity
to to watch the class of 2023 over the
past few years
most of you came here in 2019 and
experienced the pandemic As A disruption
to your first year and yourself more
year
others arrived earlier and took some
time off from your studies only recently
have we had the opportunity to
re-establish many Yale Traditions such
as this one in person
it has been a challenging time to be a
college student but you've overcome
obstacles you've thrived here at Yale
I'm reminded of some lines from one of
my favorite bands
the Grateful Dead
sometimes the lights all shining on me
other times I can barely see
lately it occurs to me what a long
strange trip it's been
but even though the last
oh yeah I wasn't going to sing it Peter
yeah but even though the last four or
five years have been a remarkable
Journey I'm delighted to see you setting
out on an even longer and perhaps an
even stranger journey ahead and I've no
doubt that you'll thrive in the world
beyond the college Gates so I've chosen
a poem about a journey for today's
reading
Constantin cavafi a modern Greek poet
born in Alexandria Egypt often rewrote
stories from the ancient world in his
poem Ithaca he addresses a person
setting out on a journey
although the addressee is not named it
seems to be Homer's Odysseus one of the
most famous Travelers in world
literature who is setting out on a
journey to his home on the Greek island
of Ithaca
but as kavafi addresses his traveler I
think each of you can imagine that he's
speaking directly to you in this
translation by Edmund Keely
Ithaca
as you set out for Ithaca hope your road
is a long one
full of Adventure full of discovery
lies dragonians Cyclops angry Poseidon
don't be afraid of them
you'll never find things like that on
your way as long as you keep your
thoughts raised high as long as a rare
excitement stirs your spirit and your
body
lies dragonians Cyclops wild Poseidon
you won't encounter them unless you
bring them along inside your soul unless
your soul sets them up in front of you
hope your road is a long one may there
be many summer mornings when with what
pleasure what Joy you enter Harbors
you're seeing for the first time
may you stop at Phoenician trading
stations to buy Fine Things mother of
pearl and coral Amber and Ebony sensual
perfume of every kind as many sensual
perfumes as you can
and may you visit many Egyptian cities
to learn and go on learning from their
Scholars
ethical always in your mind arriving
there is what you're destined for
but don't hurry the journey at all
better if it lasts for years so you're
old by the time you reach the island
wealthy with all you've gained on the
way not expecting Ithaca to make you
rich
Ithaca gave you the marvelous Journey
without her you wouldn't have set out
she has nothing left to give you now
and if you find her poor Ithaca won't
have fooled you wise as you will have
become
so full of experience
you'll have understood by then what
these ithacas mean
graduates of the class of 2023 I wish
you success and self-discovery on the
journey ahead of you thank you and
congratulations
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what's up
[Music]
are you
ready
[Music]
God
is
[Music]
amazing
Glory
[Music]
foreign
glorious
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
of the class of 2023
family members and Friends
it gives me great pleasure to welcome
you and to offer a few words this
morning
first
there is a wonderful Gale tradition
that I'd like to honor right now
so may I ask all of the families and
friends who are here today
to rise
and to recognize the outstanding and
graduating members of the class of 2023
[Applause]
and now may I ask the class of 2023
to consider all those who have supported
your arrival at this milestone
and to please rise and recognize them
[Applause]
hey that concludes the aerobic exercise
portion of our program
today
as we assemble at an inflection point in
your lives between the shortest gladdest
years of life
and exciting new chapters that lie
Beyond them
I want to discuss the importance of
community engagement here in New Haven
and in your future
so raise your hand if you participated
in a service organization on campus
or in our local community during your
time at Yale
hey that's a lot of hands
[Applause]
it's a lot of hand
not surprised because I know that nearly
all of you have immersed yourself in the
work of Civic betterment in one form or
another over the past four years
despite the rigors of your studies you
have promoted literacy with New Haven
reeds brought the basics of computer
science to Public School classrooms
through code Haven
and tutored immigrants for whom English
is not a first language as Bridges ESL
volunteers
you've likewise helped us to alleviate
housing and food insecurity through the
Yale hunger and homelessness Action
project
supported your student neighbors as
Walden peer counselors
and engaged in remedial climate action
with the urban resources initiative
even on the heels of final exams last
week
many of you volunteered in Yale Day of
Service activities
you have collectively pursued unfinished
work in our society and affirmed what
Coretta Scott King observed on this
campus in 1969 that students want to
start today
on the World of Tomorrow
although not necessarily learned in the
classroom
this Spirit of service is every bit a
part of what makes a Yale education
distinctive
and in all we estimate that you and your
classmates contributed a remarkable 150
000 hours each year
each year you were here
to community-based causes
rather than reflect on how your work in
this community will reverberate long
after you exit Phelps gate
I want to implore you to replicate it no
matter where you go next
for several years now even before the
covid-19 pandemic
this country has seen a decline in
Social Capital and the value we derive
from positive connections with other
people
political scientist Robert Putnam
diagnosed this Decay through something
that actually used to be fairly common
in my time as a teenager in Buffalo New
York
bowling leagues
Putnam
an eminent Yale alumnus observed that
more Americans are bowling
but fewer in organized leagues
so he used the Vivid metaphor of bowling
alone to represent the breakdown of
traditional social networks in
contemporary Society
as a touchstone of his thesis Putnam
pointed to a reduction in membership
among organizations like ptas the Red
Cross Lions Clubs
from its mid 20th century Peak
he found in short
that we are dropping out in droves from
organized community life
in the two decades since bowling alone's
publication
U.S census data have similarly depicted
a sharp decrease in community
involvement
the hours donated annually by volunteers
for example have between the start of
the century and your first year at Yale
and the national volunteering rate
dropped an additional seven percentage
points by the time you were a junior
so what happens when social ties weaken
certainly something is lost in our
communities
but we also Retreat into ourselves we
become isolated and we feel lonely
surveys indicate the alarming prevalence
of these feelings sixty percent of
Americans including a full 75 percent of
younger people like yourselves now
struggle with loneliness
some weeks ago this frayed social fabric
compelled U.S Surgeon General Vivek
murti also a Yale alumnus to declare a
loneliness epidemic
in America
ramifications for our health and
well-being
are wide-ranging he says
but an antidote is Within Reach
as Dr murti remarked last semester here
at Yale community service activities
connect us with somebody deeply on
something that matters but also
reaffirmed to us that we have value to
bring to the world they help us to
rebuild that esteem which gets shredded
when we are lonely
of course service activities are a
solitary for society
as they are
for ourselves
Social Capital can contribute to
positive outcomes in education
Children's Welfare the safety of our
neighborhoods economic prosperity
and even democracy itself
or Civic and social lives form the
mortar of American society and a pillar
of Public Health
we must therefore redouble our resolve
to rescue them
in doing so
we should be mindful of a distinction
articulated by philosopher John Dewey on
whom Yale bestowed an honorary degree in
1951.
many social reformers he lamented
however Noble their intentions have
failed to meet their Ambitions because
they were committed to doing good for
rather than with others
so for our part we aspire to make Yale
the most civically engaged University by
strengthening the ties that bind us to
our host City New Haven
like most of you I arrived in New Haven
as a visitor
I remember my first days at Yale as an
entering graduate student in 1981.
I was blown away by the beauty of the
stone buildings and by the tastiness of
the local pizza
over the next four decades I discovered
that New Haven is a fascinating and
Vibrant Community in which to live
the Elm City quickly became my and
Marta's home
and an integral part of our identities
your time here may well be shorter than
ours
although I urge you to consider adding
your talents to the rich mix of what
makes this a great place to work and
live
but whether you remain in New Haven or
not after graduation
we all experience a distinct bond
between Yale
and our host City
and the depth of that relationship was
reflected most recently by the historic
pledge to extend our lead as the
institution that makes the largest
annual voluntary Financial contribution
of any U.S college or university to its
home City
but
[Applause]
but a University's responsibility to its
host City goes beyond goes beyond
Financial contributions what Dewey might
have deemed worthwhile ends
it should also be intellectual it should
be innovative
it should be human
it should be with
as well as for
the metaphor of the Ivory Tower
walled off from its surroundings and at
Yale protected by moats and Gates
is no longer apt
what is real instead is a social
contract in which we willingly and
readily obligate ourselves
to the welfare of one another
so our task even as we increase our
voluntary payments
is to reinforce our culture of
Engagement
alumni such as Patricia Melton exemplify
this ideal a native of Cleveland Ohio a
1983 graduate of Yale College
and with
similar to about 20 percent of you
the first in her family to attend
college
Patricia has dedicated her career to
helping young people in our community
for over a decade she has led New Haven
promise
a yale-funded scholarship and career
development program
that is one of our most treasured
collaborations
Patricia's inspired work delivers the
dream of college for scores of young
people who otherwise wouldn't be able to
afford it
importantly the promise program
encourages college students to return to
New Haven following graduation
just as she did
the results have been superb
by the end of this decade we expect to
have welcomed back thousands of promised
alumni who will accelerate the
Renaissance well underway in our city
alongside many other Yale initiatives
such as the recently established
Pennington fellowship and the center for
inclusive growth
and we also look forward to joining the
mayor's recently announced tutoring
program for New Haven school children
it is heartening to consider these
extraordinary Community Partnerships
that alumni like Patricia unleash
and as Yale's newest graduates you can
soon enrich
before we say farewell
I wish to hearken back
to when we first met
you may recall that four years ago I
penned an open letter to welcome the
class of 2023.
in it I asked you to consider a series
of questions
among them
why are we here
why is Yale here
what is our purpose
of course improving the world through
research and education is yell's Mission
the crises that surround us pressing in
nature and often planetary and scale
compel the class of 2023 to mobilize its
unique gifts for a world in need
in the liberal education you've acquired
at Yale has prepared you well to do so
look closely though
and you will see that in a pithy mission
statement dedicating to articulating our
University's entire purpose
Yale puts equal emphasis on where we
hope to achieve it
indeed we devote ourselves to improving
the world
as we do that
we retain our focus on the
interdependent community in which this
work is advanced
ever attuned to our immediate social
surroundings
as Justice Sonia Sotomayor said to Yale
Day of Service participants some years
ago
our tradition of Civic work is expressed
in many ways including in City Halls in
state houses in Congress in the cabinet
and yes even on the Supreme Court
but this tradition of service she
continued
is also powerfully expressed daily
by countless Yale graduates fired by a
spirit
of generosity
by relief workers amidst disasters
mentors in urban schools volunteers and
Parks libraries and museums and so many
other roles
I think for instance of a former student
Caroline tanby Smith whose love for this
city was catalyzed by her president's
Public Service Fellowship
Caroline stayed in New Haven after
graduating from Yale College
and in 2017 she co-founded a non-profit
Community accelerator dedicated to
making entrepreneurship more accessible
particularly for low-income community
members women and people of color
helping them to create new jobs and
generate millions of dollars in Revenue
for this region
those efforts your efforts Justice
Sotomayor said may not make headlines
but they most surely make a difference
indeed your efforts as students engaged
in service showcase why the where of
Yale's mission statement matters
your efforts show
that the transformative
is Within Reach
that there is marvelous Grandeur in the
constellation of seemingly small acts of
service with and for each other
that together constitute a thriving
Civic life
on this campus
the sum of your contributions has
brought immense Pride to Yale and an
equal measure of progress to our
community
here you have heated Bob Dylan and
strapped yourself to a tree with roots
and nourish them
of course we hope some of you will
consider his next refrain also
you ain't going nowhere and that you
join us
right here in New Haven
but for those of you who will soon
disperse around the globe
also a fine outcome
we hope to
that you will reprise what you have done
here
we hope that you will be known as much
for your curiosity of mind
as your generosity of spirit
we hope
that wherever it is upon life's see you
sale
you will arrive there
not only as a as proud alumni of this
University
but as emissaries of its ethos
ready once again
to raise your hand
and engage
congratulations class of 2023.
thank you
Brothers
please
[Music]
I love him
again
[Music]
[Applause]
take us again
[Music]
praise
may God bless and keep you
May the Eternal show your favor and be
gracious to you
May the Holy One cause light to shine
upon you and Grant you peace
and let us say Amen
foreign
hahaha
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]